for many years I've dreamed of
multitasking with a triple display setup
through a pair of AR glasses like
Apple's Vision Pro but the problem with
those is that they're way too expensive
at 3 500 and you can't even order them
until sometime next year requiring an
appointment at Apple to buy them which
is ridiculous so when xreel reached out
to sponsor this video I saw that the air
glasses can do basically the same thing
for a tenth of the price and you can
order them today instead of waiting I
had to check them out into my surprise
their nebula for Mac app works wonders
basically upgrading a single MacBook
into a triple monitor setup that works
very well and with some very impressive
specs so before we get into how easy it
is to set up and get going I want to
show off the design they come in this
really nice and high quality carrying
case with a zipper which includes the
glasses a really nice braided USBC cable
and some additional accessories like a
microfiber cloth customizable nose pads
a prescription lens frame and a light
Shield if you want a blacked out
experience the glasses themselves feel
really nice and solid while weighing
only 79 grams with its slim and light
design which looks much more like
glasses than Apple's huge headset also
packing two open ear speakers and dual
microphones with beamforming the specs
are also super impressive with a micro
OLED display with 4K total resolution
great color accuracy with 108 srgb color
gamut the x-rail air also achieved a
world first in an AR device gaining TUV
Rhineland groups low blue light and
flicker free certification which means
they'll be safe for your eyes for
long-term use but now with that said and
out of the way I want to get into this
setup and experience with the xreel air
especially using nebula for Mac for
multitasking to get it set up all you
have to do is connect the headset to
your MacBook using the USBC cable
plugging right into one of the USBC
ports and Bam your Mac display instantly
connects and shows up in front of you no
matter where you look the quality was
actually really sharp and easy to focus
without eye strain and because it's AR
you can still see the world around you
I'm actually reading the script with the
teleprompter with the xreel air on right
now on the other hand if you want a more
immersive experience the light Shield
really helps block out the environment
and made all of the colors really pop
and look beautiful the best part is that
the x-rail air doesn't actually have any
batteries in it so it's powered by your
device like your Macbook so you don't
have to worry about battery life at all
and it works with a bunch of devices
like your iPhone steam deck and more but
the feature I really wanted to test was
multitasking with a triple monitor setup
since it'll save you so much money and
desk Space by not having to actually buy
and set up the extra monitors so I
downloaded the nebula for Mac app which
supports both Intel and apple silicon
Max and the uin settings are really
simple and easy to adjust it lets you
choose a type of desktop layout you want
with either one two or three monitors
and it worked and connected instantly
with the cursor naturally and reliably
moving between each display without any
issues at all in the settings there's a
button that you click to reset the
position of the displays just aim your
face towards your MacBook display or
wherever you want adjust the angle up
and down depending on where you'd like
them to be positioned click and Bam it
resets the position which is actually
really useful for reducing neck strain
since you no longer have to look down at
your MacBooks display but now straight
on in a comfortable neck position and
the best part is that the location of
the virtual display setup stays static
while using x-rail air using the 3dof
spatial display feature compared to
moving around when you move your head so
it works like a real triple monitor
setup which is pretty amazing what's
also really neat is that you can
completely dim your actual MacBooks
display in front of you so that it
doesn't interfere with the virtual
displays and then this way you can
easily see your keyboard and your hands
in front of you to help with typing or
with clicking certain keyboard controls
and then on the other hand you can also
put on the light shield for a completely
dark experience which is helpful if
you're in a very bright environment and
don't want any distractions near the
virtual displays and it basically gives
you complete privacy where no no one
around you can see what's on your
displays you also have a huge amount of
adjustability in the app which includes
adjusting the distance of the displays
if you don't want to have to turn your
head left and right to see all of the
different displays you can also adjust
the size if you want a full screen
experience or not and then the best part
is that you can adjust the actual angles
of the side displays even making them
completely flat and lining up with the
center monitor if you want but of course
it makes more sense to have them angled
towards you for a better experience now
as for my preferred setup I had YouTube
playing a video on the left display and
by the way the open ear speakers are
actually quite good and better than I
expected and then in the center I had my
research web tabs for looking up Apple
related leaks and general web browsing
and then on the right I actually had
this video script which I wrote while
using the axial air glasses because it
was legit legitimately more convenient
to multitask this way now another cool
feature is spatial Cinema which
basically means that you get a better
movie watching experience since you can
adjust the size of the display to be
bigger than your MacBook which is
awesome for replacing a small 13-inch
MacBook display with a huge one with the
X real air these also support 3D files
as well which you can download and play
offering a really cool 3D experience
that you can't really get anywhere else
other than physically going to the
movies I'm honestly surprised how well
this works for everything including
multitasking and how I was actually
using this instead of my usual Mac Mini
setup with a 27 inch 5K display I've got
to say that the x-rail air is
realistically the best option on the
market to experience AR and a spatial
display for your Mac it's not even close
and it's for a reasonable and affordable
price of just 379 dollars that right
there beats the thirty five hundred
dollar price of the Apple Vision Pro
headset which is honestly so expensive
that there will be a lot of people who
will never even get to experience
something like this with an AR virtual
desktop setup which is why I've got to
say Bravo to xreel for putting in the
work to make such a cool unique and
actually very useful product like the
air glasses especially the spatial
display feature where they stay in the
same position which is really cool and
as far as the reliability and settings
they did a great job nailing the
software with simple and easy
customization and I love the long
braided USBC cable which is long enough
that you don't really feel any snags or
inconveniences when using it so thank
you to xreel for sponsoring this video
and if you'd like to test this out for
yourself and purchase a pair of these
air glasses you can buy them today from
their website by using the link down in
the description below as well as the
pinned comment so hopefully you guys
enjoy this video and if you have any
questions about how these work comment
down below and be sure to click that
Circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one and definitely
check out one of those two videos right
over there thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
foreign